[Music]  here in this video we are going to  showcase to you guys a very interesting  size comparison of the predators because  we are going to include many of the ones  seen in games comics and movies so we  are going to showcase the white hybrids  the predaliens the upgrade predators the  mutated ones and even the individuals  that are very notable in their own  storylines including  the feral predator from prey so let's  get to it  [Music]  [Applause]  so  [Music]  so  [Music]  so i hope you have enjoyed watching this  video anyway with that we come to the  end of it so do hit that like button for  support and subscribe as well but most  of all smash that bell icon for regular  updates on new videos here on this  channel take care fam